a grandfather in England is claiming
that he cured his cancer using cannabis
oil so there he is right there with his
cannabis oil he first had cancer in 2009
and was given a new liver and the all
clear they said that's gone but last
year new cancerous cells were found
attacking his new organ and we've got a
little more info on what happened
my cutler started taking cannabis oil
after watching a video about how it
could cure him when he went for a biopsy
this year doctors said that the new
cancerous cells had disappeared in
research published last week scientists
at the University of East Anglia found
the main psychoactive ingredient in
cannabis I'm not even gonna try to say
that Jimmy you want to handle that one
tetrahydrocannabinol wow that Wow
that was really really good he does love
his weed hmmm had been found to limit
the growth of cancerous cells now
interestingly THC so that that's thehc
so interesting that he describes himself
as quote a family man not a druggie this
is someone who found a natural planet
now this is someone who found a natural
plant and used it for his own health and
of course this is this is a bit
antidotal i don't know that this could
work for everybody but this is this is
all good why do why are we so hung up on
this cannabis stuff number one I want to
say YouTube saves lives you saw that
video on YouTube
yeah we're saving lives people right now
right that's what's happening before
your eyes yeah so I think we're hung up
on it because ultimately weed ganja what
do they want the colleagues sorry my
Jamaican is coming very thick right now
whatever you want to name you know Mary
Jane all the the colloquialisms for it
it is a brown country's drug that's what
it is
it the places that are quote unquote
known for like where I'm from yay we're
known for so many great things like I
haven't I've never smoked weed you told
me that last time you're on the show and
I three story but well then I have to go
to the professor here unless you want to
finish the other tetra hydro I can't
even say yeah alright mr. Reid what's
the problem with these people that's
what I try to tell people you know it's
been proven that AIDS patients they use
marijuana
help secure this guy it carries cancer I
say imagine what pot will do for your
flu that's what I I take it when I have
the flu and I feel fantastic and yes
that is why that is why that is great
what about these people
what kind of psychotic person would tell
someone that has AIDS or that has cancer
or some other incurable inoperable
disease that they can't do whatever is
within their human power to do to a
mental defective like Patrick Kennedy
former congressman from Rhode Island or
maybe a Peter Lawford's kid Chris
Lawford who was also an X arrow in
junkie who was now coming on television
to tell people they shouldn't smoke pot
yeah so it's always the guys who
scratched their car at your party and
piss on your couch and then come back
when they're sober to tell you you can't
smoke pot anymore so that's who it is
and you know I'm not the first guy to
say this I saw committee and Bill Hicks
say this one time about you know when
you outlaw marijuana it is a plant that
grows freely in nature so what you're
doing is you're outlaw nature you're
saying nature is wrong and that somehow
God up when he created the world
God created the world and it was perfect
and everything in and then Olli I
left pot everywhere now I have to invent
Republicans so the heads that was Bill
hey
so that's exact that's the craziest
that's the perfect way to look at it you
are gonna outlaw nature something that
grows out of the earth is illegal so do
we basically then just need the big
pharma to jump in on this and take what
he's doing and then once they can figure
out how to give you all the side effects
when you're having diarrhea and thoughts
of suicide and restless leg syndrome and
once they get all that down then they'll
be like alright we got it in pill form
and this crazy hippie doesn't have to be
squeezing it out of a little what they
call those things little drop drop gonna
drop with that thought there's a fancy
science where a dropper thank you but
really isn't that where this is all
going that once they figure out how to
put this in pill form and they'll all be
okay it would never be as quick of a
cure as I'm taking the drops it would be
you take these pills till you die from
something else in 30 years so we could
make a ton of money off of you
a
it's it's ridiculous that medical the
medical benefits of marijuana are
seriously being outweighed by
legislation by rules by law and law is
you know we're allowed to smoke
cigarettes which have no use
right at all but to kill your ass but
marijuana that is actually have been
proven or and said there's been so many
studies of what it does for you and how
it relaxes and people with high blood
pressure be like all sorts of disorders
how there is so much medical application
with marijuana but no no that's illegal
yeah so it just tells you that at the
end of the day comes down to the agenda
of corporate America they're wanting to
make money than wanting to needing to be
able to legislate that and for me that's
what makes it not just corporate America
but corporations in general it's people
wanting to make money and if they can't
control and make money from it they're
not gonna let you get access to it
they're gonna make sure that you're
penalized if you try so remove some from
the corporate America angle to exactly
what you were saying the Bill Hicks idea
is this just that we we can't do things
that are good for us because we just
were so detached from reality you know I
mean like we're detached from the
reality of the the corporate part of it
but then we're also detached of the
natural part it's this plan and it
doesn't even register with us we are out
nothing that's like why don't you outlaw
a waterfall because people can you could
drown you can we should make that
illegal if I catch a waterfall in your
backyard
there were things that we're actively
being fed every single day yeah that
nobody nobody nobody has a problem with
that nobody you know because they're all
getting there they're there the money
off of that they're all profiting vastly
and becoming million and billion and
trillionaires and so they're fine with
that but god forbid you wanted you want
to actually take consume something that
would actually help you and circumvent
paying them a monthly oh here's my you
know medical fee for picking up my my
medicine from you when you circumvent
that you're a criminal yeah could I just
say that she's the best not pot smoking
pot advocate I bet I mean I knew what I
was going to get out of you here but
this this isn't
let me just give you one more we know
when you see these guys like Patrick
Kennedy and Chris Lawford and they come
on television and they're advocating
against legalized marijuana or medical
marijuana just know that those people
are being paid by oxycontin producers
okay that is true they that a salon or
somebody or mother jones or somebody the
nation just did over expose and that guy
Patrick Kennedy who is a piece
of
who's been going around demonizing
medical marijuana who's a drug addict
himself is on the take from oxycontin
manufacturers so always follow the money
when you hear somebody saying all them
in the marijuana today is much stronger
dollar rrrrah and you know all that but
that is and they go you know we
don't need another drug no one's saying
we need another drug people are saying
the way we deal with this the drink that
say it's already here yeah the way we're
dealing with it is bad guys it's your
show no my father was the deputy
superintendent of police for drug and
firearm administration in Jamaica for 42
years so I have a very strong
relationship to the idea of drugs and
how it should be legislated and what you
see is a lot of people in prison a lot
of people are systems are overloaded
with crap from marijuana and marijuana
is the least problematic of the drugs
that are on the market and yet it is the
one that is the most demonized so I have
a huge issue with that which is why I'm
their biggest non pot smoker yeah no
joke I literally I was watching I was
growing a little weed in my tiny little
garden a little like somebody gave me a
seat I was growing a little weed and
then I was watching orange is the new
black I swear to God and I paused it in
the middle and I ripped up the weed and
I was like I don't want to end up in a
women's prison